first off I have to ask about economists
confidence in their own ability to
forecast out 35 years is it is this a
kind of a deadlock a done deal well they
try they struggle to a project three to
five months little in 35 years very much
not a done deal an interesting academic
exercise and one a lot of economists
undertake you look at a Jim O'Neill
formerly of Goldman Sachs and the BRICS
concept economists like to kind of plot
out a route to the future and that's
what the Economist Intelligence units
doing here but with some interesting
findings that they're not without
completely outside the realms of
possibility well obviously we see the
juggernaut of China it's not hard to
believe that they'll completely overtake
everyone else but it's interesting to
see countries like Mexico growing larger
and larger and influenced absolutely
these emerging markets they've all got
catch-up potential Mexico by virtue of
being so close to the US can be pulled
higher and by its neighbor China you
just look at how big it is how
productive it can be what a what spare
capacity exists at the moment its
population trends all these things are
adding up to something we weren't even
talking about 10-15 years ago and now
China is a is on the move or the
important to note that even by the IU's
forecasted in 2050 its per capita income
will still be a half that of the US by
those projections so it was still a poor
country but yet a big country and
growing fast Simon give us your sense of
how the prospects for China verse India
stack up you know the past ten years
people have been saying oh India's got
this fabulous demographic advantage
because obviously you know China the
one-child policy they're going to have a
smaller and smaller workforce going
ahead how do you see them stacking up
well obviously China was the big store a
couple years ago it's now been replaced
by by India certainly recent trends in
India a good got a new government
talking about cutting bureaucracy and
red tape and and that could go a long
way to unleashing India which forever
has been criticized as being an overly
bureaucratic country China on the flip
side is
taking taking a bit of a pause lately uh
gross still growing 7% maybe a bit less
but perhaps not the double-digit speed
that we saw a few years ago certainly
India has the momentum now Russia The
Economist Intelligence Unit doesn't give
a lot of credit to Vladimir Putin's
attempt to enlarge the borders I guess
they don't see that going much further I
think probably Russia and most
economists agree is it's it's perhaps
its own worst enemy it came out of the
Cold War with some great potential and a
potential obviously linked to oil or to
some extent which a bit outside its
control has has fallen now subject to
international sanctions these are things
that if the future was to be cleared up
perhaps there are blips in the path to
it to greater economic growth but it
certainly don't really see the the way
out at the moment this is this strikes
me as one of the things that's really
difficult to predict especially 35 years
out I mean economists don't know what
oil is going to be priced at next year
right so that Simon what do you think of
the growth rates were assuming well
that's the tricky thing with these kind
things so it's a Jim O'Neill at Goldman
would say that he never said that the
BRICS rise would be a straight line to
the moon it would be one of bumps and
and peaks and troughs and that
eventually they would get to where he
was saying I always suspect the EIU
would say the same that this is a
projection based on trends but there any
one of which can be a blown asunder by
outside shocks or internal shocks in the
case of Russia all right Simon thanks so
much for joining us Simon Kennedy there
Bloomberg chief international economics
correspondent on a look it's a fun I
wouldn't say a parlor trick it's a fun
it's it's a it's an exercise and
academic exercise as Simon pointed out
looking ahead 35 years it is and it's
interesting that actually fundamental
growth factors matter as much as
demographics the big assumption
obviously being that we're all still
here